Speaker 1: Jorge Santos. Anthony Deveaux. Older.
Who am I talking about? Well, apparently it's
the same guy, many of you. Last week, when I said
George Santos slash Anthony Duvall, who wrote to
me and said, David, what? What are you talking
about? What do you what do you mean by that?
People wrote in asking about this in 2019. Jorge
Santos introduced himself not as Jorge Santos,
but as Anthony Duvall, the founder of United
for Trump. This was a walk away LGBT event
in New York City. The idea being it's for LGBT
people to abandon the Republican Party. Here's a
familiar looking and sounding guy who says,
My name is Anthony. Devolved there. Yeah.
Where the hater. Oh, you got to be married.
Speaker 2: So my name is Anthony Voltaire.
I'm a New York City resident. I recently founded a
group called United for Trump. So if you guys want
to follow, that would be awesome. My questions
directed for both Blair and Brandon. Well,
Brandon's an idol to all of us. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Anthony Dave Alder. What is that? Now,
if you look at his Wikipedia page, apparently
his full name is George Anthony, devoted there
Santos. Is that accurate? I guess. Probably.
This is not the first time that this has come
up. There's actually some amazing video during his
2020 campaign. A guy who introduced Santos Duvall
there at the Queens Village Republican Club was
actually confused and said, this guy, I know this
guy. Is Anthony there? I don't even understand
what's going on here. This is this amazing.
Speaker 3: Folks, another important speaker, the
other congressional nominee of George Santos.
George, who we know is a friend and he's known as
the Anthony is of old to me. So I don't know where
George Santos came into the thing, but that's what
it says here. Yeah, he's the Republican candidate.
Speaker 1: This guy's like, I've been handed
a piece of paper that says, This guy is George
Santos, but I've known him as Anthony Davis older.
And indeed, here is another video in which he
introduces himself as Anthony Davis older.
Speaker 2: Good evening, everybody. My name
is Anthony de Voltaire. I recently founded a
movement called United for Trump on Facebook.
Speaker 1: And by the way, I have to tell you, he
founded a movement. This is typical of people who
have these delusions of grandeur. I founded
a movement. Dude, you made a Facebook page,
okay? That's what you did. You founded a movie.
It's a real movement. It's incredible. It's like
Reform Judaism. It's just an unbelievable
movement that has taken the world by storm.
Next thing would be that people have written to me
about this, and I hope this doesn't come up. Next
thing will be that he says he's trans or something
like that. Let's hope it doesn't get to that
point. What is his real name? Apparently, it's
George Anthony Santos, the older Anthony George,
Double Bolder, Santos. Something along
those lines we may never really know.